I grew up in a family where my father
managed all the money but for some
reason when I was eight or nine years
old he started showing me things about
money we would sit at the kitchen table
and he'd show me all the bank books now
that was back in the day before the
internet when we used to have little
books that we used to keep our
information in and he would show me how
he's saved in these accounts and he paid
bills out of these and every time he
would show this I think about money he
would end by saying and don't you tell
your mother now to this day I really
don't know why he said that but what I
do know is to that eight-year-old girl
sitting at the kitchen table
it meant don't say a word
years later when I got my first job my
father said you'll bring me your check
and I'll put it in the bank for you but
because of what he had taught me years
before I said I'd like my bank book and
to my surprise he gave it to me right
then at 16 years old I began managing my
own money I went on to college and then
to start my new career as a CPA but now
with student loans getting an apartment
and a new job I began the roller coaster
ride of accumulating debt paying it off
in accumulating more many years later
after getting married I went through an
unexpected divorce and I was left with a
house I couldn't afford and bills I
couldn't pay you might be wondering how
does it happen to someone that's
educated and skilled at managing
people's money I had reverted back to
what I learned growing up that one
person managed all the money I had
handed over my financial power and I had
become financially dependent financial
dependency is when someone is dependent
on a person a job or situation for money
and they feel trapped people fall into
two categories dependent with choice and
dependent without a choice someone is
dependent with choice when they hand
financial power and their participation
it can happen in personal or business
relationships when one person doesn't
want to be involved with the money so
they hand over the responsibility to a
spouse a partner or professional like an
accountant or a manager
this was my situation I spent all day
long managing other people's money so I
was relieved that my husband was
interested and good at managing owners I
was free for the first time since that
first job at 16 years old
I didn't have to be responsible for
managing my money but what I failed to
realize was what felt like freedom was
really dependency my mistake is that I
didn't stay involved or understand what
was going on with our money you may have
experienced this yourself or you may
have heard stories of celebrities or
professional athletes that have relied
on family friends and others to manage
their money and they are left broke
bankrupt and betrayed because they made
the choice to hand over their financial
power someone that's dependent without a
choice feels trapped because of their
financial situation they can be in a job
or career where they're unhappy or being
harassed but they can't afford to leave
or someone that's had to move in with
family and friends because they've had
an illness or gone through a divorce or
experienced a tragedy and now they're
financially dependent on others and how
many of us know someone that has an
elderly parent or a relative that can no
longer take care of themselves and
they're left to rely on others sometimes
handing over their homes their money and
other assets another type of dependency
without a choice is financial abuse
financial abuse is a pattern of abusive
behavior used to control and intimidate
a partner victims are in a relationship
and the other person has power over them
because they don't have access to money
information or the resources and support
they need to leave the Allstate
Foundation has a program called the
purple purse
that helps victims of domestic violence
through financial empowerment they
report that 99% in 99 out of 100
domestic violence cases financial abuse
helps keep victims trapped in their
relationship
the purple purse has coined financial
abuse the invisible weapon because
physical abuse leaves bruises and scars
but financial abuse doesn't financial
abuse and financial dependency leave
emotional scars that you can't see they
include hopelessness guilt shame
depression lack of confidence and self
esteem financial dependency is also
invisible because no one's talking about
it
why because no one wants to show their
emotional scars and because we're taught
in our homes at our jobs and in our
community not to talk about money so
many people that I talk to about this
issue they can relate and they have a
story but they're not telling anyone
their story when I was to load the
kitchen table don't you tell I never
told anyone it's even hard for me right
now to break that rule that I learned so
long ago so what can I do what can you
do what can we all do to disarm this
invisible weapon we can solve three
problems the first problem is lack of
awareness because knowing about money
and having money aren't always the
solution in my situation as educated and
experienced in managing money but that
didn't stop me from becoming financially
dependent why because of the beliefs and
experiences I had growing up one person
manages all the money after my divorce I
had to rebuild my life financially and
emotionally so I took every
self-development course and I read every
self-help book I could find and that's
when I began to understand the dynamics
of the family that I live grew up in and
how they played a role in me handing
over my financial power when you become
aware of your inner bruises and scars
you
begin to break free from financial
dependency the next problem is lack of
information about financial literacy
financial literacy is having the skills
and the knowledge to make informed
decisions about your money it includes
topics like savings and investing
budgeting and debt in 2018 only 17
states required financial literacy in
high school curriculums this corresponds
with recent studies that show that
sixty-six percent of Americans are
financially illiterate if you are in a
financial dependency situation start by
by looking and going through your
finances making decisions participate
making decisions about your money if you
are in a financial abuse situation get
access to your information look for
financial documents like bank credit
card statements social security
information and account passcodes the
last problem is lack of giving and
getting support many people don't know
that there are free resources online and
in your local community to help you
learn and establish healthy money habits
there are also free resources if you are
a victim of financial abuse like the
purple purse giving support includes
listening to others that are financially
dependent without judgment or criticism
it also involves sharing your story
because when you share your story you
empower others and you give them the
permission to rewrite their own it's my
hope that by sharing my story more
people will learn about financial
dependency will share their own stories
and will connect with others to shed a
light on this hidden issue so that we
can all have financial freedom
[Applause]
[Music]